on a tout fait depuis 15 jours pour que
tout soit prêt pour le 11
c'est à dire le jour de la rentrée des
enseignants où ils viennent pour faire
leur formation sanitaire et
l'installation des classes comme ça des
enseignants auront le lundi le mardi
voir le mercredi 6 est elle nécessaire
avant d'accueillir les hanches nous il
fuit à plaisir on a dans les écoles
maternelles un quota de entre cinq et
dix enfants en maternelle maximum et en
élémentaire entre 10 et 15 enfants
maximum en tenant compte que bien sûr on
priorise l'acceptation des enfants dont
on a eu la liste par le gouvernement à
partir de là il ya des écoles qui vont
pouvoir en plus des enfants qui sont
prioritaires et accueillir d'autres
enfants de parents qu'ils ne sont pas et
dans certaines écoles le plan qui sera
fait avec les enfants prioritaire donc
tout ça sur une période je dirais déjà
une quinzaine de jours jusqu'au
pratiquement fin mai et ensuite selon
l'assouplissant on verra comment on peut
augmenter le nombre d'enfants a accepté
dans les écoles